so earlier this week Riot put up a
couple of job postings searching for
game designers to help work on valorent
now ordinarily this wouldn't even be
newsworthy in the slightest what makes
these postings special is that they were
specifically catered to the console
version of valorant
it's been rumored for some time but it
does finally seem as if Riot are going
to allow controllers to play on well
controllers the question is whether
that's actually a good thing
foreign
let's start with the postings themselves
back in 2020 right after valorin's
closed beta came out the express quoted
former game director Joe Ziegler as
saying that Riot were exploring the
possibility of releasing their shooter
on other platforms after they'd finished
polishing up the PC launch fast forward
two and a half years we're seeing job
postings live and in print asking for
candidates to think about how they'd
quote transform valorent into the
definitive tactical shooter for consoles
now I know what you're thinking
console isn't the whole point of alleren
supposed to be that it's sweaty and Cs
go-esque and the place where the shrouds
and the tenses are styling on kids
nowadays like how are you supposed to
play Jet with a controller and
more importantly why would you want to I
don't want to conjure the whole debate
here but for those who genuinely aren't
aware the accepted wisdom is that aiming
with one's thumbs is just inherently
more limiting than aiming with one's
entire arm wrist and hand and just think
about it right the range of this is a
lot smaller than all of this if you're
interested in a deeper and more
technical explanation of this check out
the cracked we did on aim assist and the
mechanics of mouse aiming vis-a-vis
controller aiming now a lot of you may
not actually realize this but up until
very recently PC gaming has just never
ever really been big in North America
compared to other markets in the world
it wasn't really until fortnite and the
streaming boom that it gave way to that
kids in North America started noticeably
veering away from Xbox and PlayStation
and focusing instead on building PCS and
getting really really good with mouse
and keyboard prior to that it was all
Call of Duty all the time I came up on
1.6 and even I lived and breathed Modern
Warfare back in 2009 when I was 16. I
was a cool edgy PC aimer back when that
was not common in n a and even I was
calling in nukes and flexing my 2.0 KD
with the rest of them this is also one
of the reasons why Counter-Strike is and
always has been way bigger in Europe
than in North America consoles were just
never really all the rage over there
those Danes never got sidetracked by
turtle beaches and in quick scoping
montages those mothers grew up on Dust
too the point of all of this is to
impress upon you that PC gaming is
honestly still a relatively recent
phenomenon in North America and to
contextualize why it is that releasing a
triple A Plus title on Console can still
allow you to reach an unimaginably large
audience here in North America if and
when this port were to occur there would
be literally countless Cod Bros Madden
fiends and literal actual 10 year olds
who would flock to valorent as soon as
Mom said that it's their turn to play on
the Xbox this is exactly what happened
with Minecraft and it quite literally
became one of the biggest video games on
the planet it's also what valve tried to
do with Counter-Strike but we're never
really able to pull it off yes there was
such a thing as Counter-Strike on the
original Xbox and CS go on newer Xboxes
and they were awful in the best
ways possible mind you this was in the
era before mouse and keyboard on Console
was really a thing but you can imagine
how big a title like valorent could
actually get on current generation
consoles and this makes sense because we
know that the bigger that Riot gets the
more they want to turn their titles into
mainstream media Empires it isn't just
world songs and Esports tournaments it's
things like Arcane and players and we
all know that to become truly truly
Normy
you gotta get your game on console that
said there are some wrinkles that Riot
will have to iron out running a premier
Esports grade shooter on both console
and PC is no easy feat there are
genuinely some platform discrepancies
that they're going to have to take into
consideration the most obvious of which
is it input some of you may not know
this but back in the early days of
Rainbow Six Siege which in my opinion is
pretty much the closest analog to what
valorent will eventually become should
consoles enter the mix used to have two
pro leagues and World Championships one
for pce and one for Xbox eventually
Ubisoft decided to scrap the Xbox One
not only because having one league is
just cleaner and better but again
because the skill ceiling on mouse and
keyboard is just higher and more fun to
watch several console Pros did switch
over some of whom became massively
successful like waxing Skies or Bosco
and professional Siege became this one
unified free-for-all the reason I'm
saying all of this is because it's very
unlikely in the year of Our Lord 2022
that Riot would adopt such a
dichotomized structure imagine having
two Champions one for the serious PC
players and another one where dudes try
to play Jet with analog sticks that said
they would have a split player base the
casuals on console and the sweats on PC
from issues of cross play and auto aim
to mouse and keyboard on Console being
Paramount to cheating to just plain old
elitism it is a nightmare a lucrative
nightmare that will almost inarguably
benefit valorant in the long run but a
nightmare nonetheless which brings us to
the hairiest and most interesting of
said obstacles
which has been struggling with this for
years there are literally guns that are
considered s-tier on PC but whose recoil
renders them unusable on console and
while there are absolutely Esports
Sports where the boys on the sticks hold
their own against the mouse and keyboard
players just fine like Apex Legends I
think it's fair to say that that will
probably never be the case in valorant
so long as Riot never implements any
sort of auto aim you'll almost be
guaranteed to need a mouse to be
competitive it's the same reason no
one's really played Counter-Strike with
a controller in the past 20 plus years
the game is just so focused around
Crosshair placement and recoil control
it's just even controller players use
mouse and keyboard anyway it'll be
interesting to see how Riot reconciles
these issues and the extent to which
they feel they need to when designing
additional agents and abilities do they
construct two different aiming
infrastructures or unify them both into
one hole now I should also say that this
has all probably been in the back of
Riot's mind since valorin's Inception
it's safe to assume that they always
knew they were going to at the very
least eyeball a console release and are
preparing for it accordingly
hence the job postings not only do they
have a near infinite amount of resources
but balance hold shtick is that they
learned from everybody else's mistakes
and created the perfect shooter with 128
tick a real anti-cheat great visibility
and absolutely zero peeker's advantage
although the jury is still really out on
that last one so yeah it'll be genuinely
interesting to see how Riot chooses to
smooth out these platform discrepancies
I have zero depth that Riot can in fact
create the definitive tax shooter for
console I just want to see how they do
it and what it will spell for valorent
as a whole
League of Legends on Console anything
can happen I wonder if it's like playing
Diablo on controller when they release
Diablo 3 on consoles people were like
what because for like 25 plus years
Diablo has always been a PC game so but
it turned out to be better the biggest
issue man is the camera is The Edge pan
and and right you need to lock your
camera to your Champion basically in
order to make it playable and that's
like a whole other Vibe right